Bueller? Bueller?
American education is
rife with grand policy proposals that
have turned into bureaucratic fiascos,
from school turnaround to the Common
Core. This is Big 'R' reform. Big 'R'
reform takes the hot idea of the moment,
invests it with grand enthusiasm, and then
tells doubters and skeptics that they
better get on board or get the heck out
of the way. I first saw this stuff up
close a quarter century ago when I was
teaching high school in Baton Rouge,
Louisiana. At the time, the hot new reform
in the state was a teacher evaluation system.
The idea was laudable: Make sure teachers
are doing their jobs well. The solution: a
checklist with a hundred and thirty odd items that administrators
dragged into classrooms. It was nonsense!
Good schools are intensely human places.
They are formed by thousands of good
judgments on the part of teachers that
they make every day. This is why grand
bureaucratic fixes tend not to make a
big difference for schools.
This is the problem with Big 'R' reform,
and it's why there are better ways to
give our kids schools they deserve.
To learn more about my take on the problem
of Big 'R' reform, check the links in
the description below. Also, let us know
what other topics you'd like AEI
scholars to cover in 60 seconds.